our car expert matakovich says this is
old-school diesel technology this engine
is a hundred and ten years old it's a
bit loud and clunky and it's a bit
smelly here too at the Diesel House
Museum in Copenhagen Matti says that
even though diesel engines were built
into cars early on diesel was still a
synonym for slow but that all changed
with this car here the Audi 102.5 TDI
which made its debut in 1989 now the
technology has come so far you can win
them Wong's with a diesel Matt it says
the rs5 TDI concept proves that it's not
the end of the road for innovations yet
he's gonna take it out for a spin on the
racetrack howdy is using the rs5 TDI
concept car to show off its new diesel
technology under the hood the 3-liter
TDI twin-turbo produces 283 kilowatts of
power rocketing the car from 0 to 100
kilometres an hour in just 4 seconds and
in addition to its conventional exhaust
driven turbocharger it's also equipped
with an electric one
Oh
Munda Kennedy Howdy's Yan Riker says
that conventional turbo charges have a
compressor on one side and a turbine on
the other now he says to imagine that
the turbine side has been replaced by an
electric motor creating an electric
turbocharger the electric turbocharger
increases the engines power very quickly
and smoothly even at low revs
I thought Matty says anyone looking for
a car to do extreme drifting shouldn't
pick the rs5 TDI as the Quattro
all-wheel drive ensures great traction
at all times the rs5 is covered in black
matte foil with red highlights its
diesel engine isn't the only first the
combination of a diesel and an RS model
is also new so far only two rs5 TDI's
have been built with no more coming
anytime soon there are no plans to put
them into series production the new
diesel specs fit in perfectly with the
rs5 sporty interior howdy
has not yet sounded out the market for
the diesel drive for this model that
comes next matter says the Audi rs5 TDI
concept doesn't sound like a TDI doesn't
sound like a diesel it sounds like you
would expect an rs5 - throaty full and
powerful but funnily enough he says if
he switches from dynamic to comfort on
the Audi Drive select menu then it
sounds like an Audi three litre diesel
engine quiet smooth and pleasant - my ID
once under the name so what's the secret
behind the different engine sounds
yamaneika reveals that at the end of the
exhaust system there's an active sound
actor which imitates the classical sound
of a gas-powered v8 engine the
retractable rear spoiler adds more
downforce reducing lift on the rear axle
Matis is also impressed by the
acceleration
he says he'll just stop here on the
racetrack now he steps on the gas and
says the car really takes off without
any turbo lag he finds it phenomenal the
rs5 TDI is still a concept car outtie
has yet to decide which models will
offer the new diesel engine
you